[Música]
sempre gostei ela a mão na cabeça eo
pessoal como a música não discrimina a
naiá sistema mirante no roma
vamos ficar aí ela quer ser um
milionário com você eu quero dizer a
você que é de teresina no piauí teresina
quinta feira agora nós teremos um show
beneficente está o show para arrecadar
fraldas para o abrigo são lucas fraldas
geriátricas fraudas vem a quinta feira
agora dia 21 no theatro 4 de setembro
como é que você vai fazer para uma
bagunça love todo mundo pra fazer chegar
lá não tem lugar pra entrar vai no
theatro 4 de setembro você deixa o seu
nome lá com sua identidade está e no
outro dia você volta pra entregar a
fralda geriátrica e um pacote de leite
que foi isso que o pessoal de lá falou
que precisava e na entrega do pacote de
fralda geriátrica você recebe o seu
ingresso para assistir o show no theatro
4 de setembro está em obras são lucas
precisa de fraldas geriátricas ea gente
vai ajudá-la dia 21 quinta-feira lá no
theatro 4 de setembro já saber mais
informações falar no instagram que lá
tem tudo direitinho tá bom como é que se
faz a gente ajudar o abrigo solo e vai
ter muito sol também é esse final de
semana em belém do pará em manaus em
fortaleza também em recife em montes
claros que já foi adiado no dvd do show
agora vai ter lá uma esquadra então pode
entrar no meu site onde você comprou
ingresso também se pode ver sua cidade
está lá e rio de janeiro vai ter o dever
de r em um papo está aqui um dvd em um
ingresso também no site eu fui assistir
it a coisa vocês pediram tanto nos
comentários e eu fui assistir e olha
antes de começar o vídeo eu já vou falar
pra você que tem spoiler assim esse
vídeo esse vídeo é que eu vou ter que
falar muita coisa fácil só que eu vou
lhe dizer uma parada nada do que eu
disse aqui é comparado ao que você vai
ver na tela do cinema nada de verdade
pra mim pra falar a verdade um dos
filmes mais roda de terror se eu já
assisti a muitos filmes de terror e
contei aqui pra vocês o susto que levei
na verdade foi o assunto que no final o
filme é tanto mais cara de verdade
e se a coisa o filme de terror mais [__]
que eu já senti na minha vida então já
no começo eu peço a você que vai deixar
o gosto da etapa que muitos de vocês vão
até o final do vídeo esquece clicar
gostei eu estou repetindo assim todo o
vídeo fixa acaba de você meu prometo que
vou parar de falar isso mas deixou a
equipe logo porque quando você não da
light no vídeo o youtube para de enviar
esse vídeo caro é simples e ta danu
liquidá la ea máquina entende e gosta
então vamos mandar pra ele vai deixar de
dar lá e ele vai parar de chegar pra
você às vezes e ps eu não tenho vida no
vídeo eu já peguei uns quatro porque
você não tá dando ok então tudo que
gostei e agora já aproveita esse tempo
que gosto e vamos ouvir eu fui assistir
lá no cinema eu fui com luiza ea luiza
mulheres e sabe ela morre de medo de
filme de terror filme assim o que está
acontecendo na música acontecendo e
também lá tal pipoca eu acrescentei pa
começou o filme em correr atrás do
marquinhos
na chuva o barquinho assim é me
indiferente beijo beijo fosse meu
barquinho por esgoto falavam e morreu
barquinho foi bom fazer é esse aqui não
é o barquinho de esgoto e aparece um
palhaço ele começa a conversar com o
menino começa a pagar todos se babando
aquela copa foi essa a minha em mim sabe
assim você sabe que era atrasada de mim
de filme eu tenho ódio ao parar de falar
assim eu vim pegar seu barquinho quando
menino estende a mão para pegar o
barquinho o palhaço arranca o braço do
menino para ficar assim ó tu tá ligado
domínio de filme o beijo em sacos com o
toquinho assim pelo chelsea é o palhaço
um chuveiro banheira minha mulher ela se
assusta mais que tudo e sabe aquelas
pessoas que que você ri da risada dela
luiza ao contrário eu me espanto com o
espanto da ossu buscar tomar o meu é
três vezes maior porque nem com o filme
com ela do meu lado só do barulho que
ela escutou de arrancar o braço ministro
pelo amor de deus a paz ou chito também
os assusta contudo viu aí é [__]
assistir a singular da pessoa sim e ela
perguntando o que está acontecendo
porque foi nada não o palhaço coisa ok
matou o menino aí o filme aquela boneca
4 amigo taupin eu já sei que vai dar
merda eu vejo quatro crianças junto
fazendo é dar certo para crescer junto
uma criança sozinha na casa já arregaça
torno de r 4 mil
mas saí de bullying sabe eles vivem no
colégio aqueles bolinhos de de filmes há
barracas
lutei lutei foco users a ii e caras o
que acha de tchizo aquelas crianças do
3º ano que é luverci luta ele usa 1000
seus pés e dois perdedores só quilos e
estava que as crianças sentem ódio
quando vê mas não é um boom muito bom
ler se que o bullying de filme
eu acho que eles falam eles fazem assim
vou fazer um boneco mas está não dá
exemplo as pessoas militar então vamos
fazer um bolo efraim um dos menino a dos
apelidos que ele falava assim tá aí
novatos eo novato da turma às 10 00 no
fato de que eu não vá achar ruim de novo
rap isso léo bulling a minha escola um
amigo meu apelido era a cabeça de
brinquedo era um apelido assim mais
gente boa que eu quero botar minha hora
que um dos mineiros vai vai deixar uma
carga de trabalho típico negócio de
carne vai deixar um lugar começa a sair
fumaça da porta lado lugar sem saimon
queimado um bom time toca muito chato do
trabalho paciente filme não aí meu amigo
começa a aparecer coisa toda é um menino
que está orando na igreja pensa que não
o quadro da igreja começa a sair vai
atacar o menino novo que o menino lá ele
está na no lê nos livros de história e
descobre que foi o que aconteceu com a
cidade que teve o tipo explosão num
circo lado nada italiano levou um balão
passa balão vermelho vai passando assim
a pelo meio de todo mundo a seleção de
boné dele é como ele faz ele vai atrás
né o jumentinho vai atrair o e burro ele
vai atrás sozinho e não chega nem a
venda do negócio você vem aqui ver que
passou um balão aqui achei meio suspeito
este balão passando só assim não ele foi
sozinho e vai descendo as escadas porque
não é pra trás tem uma pessoa na escada
ea pessoa vai descendo tac para a pessoa
deve ser de grau dez degraus com 10 o
outro degrau cada cabeça da pessoa [__]
merda o ministério recebe o rennes saiu
correndo e ele vem correndo assim meio
de costa por ele vira pra frente onde os
angels também o palhaço a cabeça do
palhaço do tamanho de um caraigá baralho
fosse nessa hora ia falar vai quebrando
seu toda maldição eu sonho em poder de
deus de misericórdia me livrar desse
capeta senhor galo está acontecendo a
mãe quero ver meu amor em nome de jesus
não olha que essa tela que deus vem está
quebrando meu
o bicho é muito fez então ligar eles
sofrem bullying pra carai então a menina
essa galerinha e tem uma cena que ela tá
no banheiro ela começa a ouvir uma voz
da pia e vem escutando as vozes na pia e
ela vai se aproximando e fica ouvindo
que apita falando com ela sim eu digo e
repito especial de filme é me lesado eu
tô de boa em casa com o meu médico e
tranquilo nada escutar pia conversando
comigo eu já começo a e quebrando o
senhor toda feitiçaria e todo o mal que
tem escape assim o que o senhor vê está
livrando aparece outro de mim atrás de
mim é verdade sim um nome de jesus meu
deus que o seu bem-estar esteve na tua
mão sobre esta pia pai fala bem eu falo
eu te peço meu deus que o senhor está
removendo todo mal toda obra de
feitiçaria vai quebrando senhor com o
teu nome do teu nome tem poder é jesus
fala de deus falou que não tem condição
não consigo não consigo a menina começa
a chegar perto da pia vai escutando ela
vai escutando o que eu penso que não
comece a jorrar sangue da pia na cara
dela ea bebes aiglon o sangue pela
fábrica atacar o sangue pelo corpo tudo
cheio de sangue eu acho interessante que
isso acontece o menino da igreja o
quadro saiu virou kpmg do açougue humor
de mão pelas paredes da biblioteca vi um
balão voando fui lá tinha lá o palhaço
satanás é outra menina estava andando
pela rua de um horto vivo que o barco
saiu correndo
viu também o palhaço do capiroto dia
todo mundo se encontra todo conversando
normal coisa normais pois certas mas a
vida e depois é de um ano a escola é
paire usar nota ruim mas começa a
conversar como se nada tivesse
acontecido e se fosse comigo eu visse um
palhaço um 2018 assim é um tapete e 2029
um palhaço parece por 1050 eu não
pagasse eu com 100 anos de idade
a rifa abandona o meu bolão é o grupo
eu me dei a eles começam os 4 a
pesquisar as coisas nova amiguinha da
igreja vêm da salgueiro a minha do
sangue no banheiro mini 7 parece jorge
tem um time certinho km 7 psg a mãe dele
é tipo sobre o protetor não deixei de
sair de cada hora de a gente não vai
canta ele se reúne para fazer uma
pesquisa para saber o que foi que
aconteceu foi que o antecedeu e é nessa
pesquisa ele descobre um disco palhaço
horas bota algumas imagens um
retroprojetor e começa a ver algumas
fotos né pra poder encontrar onde o
palhaço hora de descobre o retroprojetor
começa a passar um monte de fotos onde
vai passar as fotos sozinha vai passando
as fotos sozinho passando as fotos
enquanto penso que é uma das pessoas da
foto começa a virar o palhaço vai dando
um zoom no palhaço no palhaço no palhaço
no palhaço no palhaço de novo a meu deus
vou embora você tivesse uma o palhaço e
imensos carnaval de verdade assim a uma
coisa assim que dá medo mesmo não
consigo transformar em palavras aquela
cena ou até passar ponto porque eu não
consigo ver que eles fazem eles
descobrem de palhaço mora ele se reúne e
vão na casa do pai na época morreu uma
desgraça de pessoas como eu falasse o
palhaço mora onde é pra lá ou coisa boa
vou falar viu falei lá eles vão na casa
entra na casa a casa menor sombra lógica
um capeta está lá é o mínimo que poderia
ser uma sombra eles entram na casa a
casa toda regas ada tudo cheio de poeira
o modo de roupas pelo chão pois ao invés
de comida as coisas em tudo sujo eu
falei [__] para filmar aqui em casa
eu não vi eles começam a ver onde cuida
da casa que dá medo porque é isso que o
palhaço que ele quer que a pessoa sinta
medo porque o medo alimento palhaço
entendeu exemplo o dia que parece jardim
quando está caminhando ele vê uma pessoa
morta e irmã ganhou palhaço já ganhou o
do dinheiro numa sala cheia de coisa
coberto um monte de coisas coberta
daquele menino vai caminhar devagarzinho
as coisas coberta com um monte de pano
competição faz um monte de palhaço
olhando agora de verdade eu entro no
quarto tem um monte de coisa roberto
donato pai do qual o óleo tem um monte
de palhaço do satanás olhando pra mim
começa como usá que eu quero subir nessa
hora aparece outro de mim fazendo
segunda voz atrás de mim mais alto que
eu puder
é só pra te ver se aparece outro de mim
do lado é verdade jesus fala meu amigo
esse quarto uns 30 palhaços palhaços
grande pequeno igor bago alto baixo
tiririca do mais feito nada para gastar
em casa na minha casa eles correm o
menino corre o palhaço ocorre quando o
palhaço vai pegar a menina me enfio um
capacete na cabeça do paraná saiu
devagar que levou à cacetada na cabeça e
todo mundo sai banga de dessa casa
porque ambiental [__] merda eu ia morrer
o outro fala eu ia morrer eu não aguento
mais eu não vou mais junto com você eu
vou embora não quero morrer com o povo
de palhaço caranã o grupo se desfaz hora
que eu mais senti medo de perder fora o
caminho estava no banheiro quando ela
virou para trás tom o palhaço brother
não foi um susto que me quem sabe com um
susto que eu tava muito diz prevenir
sabe quando a música te prepara ela vai
fazendo assim quando isso é um susto
preparada um sus e vastas sabe que vai
vir tanto você faz até assim mas isso
não estava preparado que não teve música
não teve nada quando pensou que não fez
ou palhaço brother eu tava com a pipoca
na boca em goleada tão rápida que a
pipoca foi diretamente para a boca do
curso eu queria uma florzinha assim é só
quando assim é não guardar distância ele
sabe que o palhaço hora vai vai matar
todo mundo ele se reúne de novo e cada
um terá uma barra de ferro ou travar o
negócio de matar bom exemplo na casa de
novo e vão lá num pulso onde o palhaço
mesmo estava da [__] não vou entrar
dentro do bolso cara ou pouco a procurar
coisa no inter que se fosse eu ia ficar
na porta eu ia ser um jogo você vê esse
é o cara que fica na porta malas é
rapaziada precisa ficar aqui que pode
chegar alguém e eu não quero vocês
correm um risco aqui vulneráveis
tá bom vamos fazer o seguinte vou ficar
aqui na porta e qualquer coisa ela era
aí que tá solta aqui querendo entrar sou
cagão vou falar a verdade o filme de
terror durador minuto comigo você tinha
coisa eo y e assim paypal aliás e um
emprego subir acabou o filme a menina
está bem desse buraco que na hora do
susto palhaço levou me para dentro do
poço quando ela acorda talhar o circo do
palhaço dançarina vai fazer tipo
showzinho a menina tá ligado pra dar
medo que é isso que os atuais faz só não
chegue mata na hora do tipo shows em
primeiro está vou vou tremer esta casa
que é a menina não tem medo dele vai lhe
mostrar que ela tem medo ele abre
boca meu amigo é tanto dentro dessa boca
essa sim um lixeiro de dentista no final
do dia é aquela história né quatro
meninos dentro de um poço o que é que
pode dar errado né galera começa a se
distanciar um vai para um lado vai pôr
os atuais a pedra da lua tenta dar lhe
um palhaço aparece ali aparece popular
eu sei que do nada é que do nada aquela
musiquinha de suspense e nessun dorma
tava tudo me cagando realiza disse assim
que está acontecendo no mundo eu
respondi nem o do nada quem é que
aparece um menino começo do filme
esse lindo filme olha com uma calma para
essa criança que tinha morrido há não
sei quantos anos atrás que se encontra a
pessoa que morreu não sei quantos anos
atrás por um palhaço que arrancou o
braço da pessoa ou certeza de nada o
comércio vai quebrando se o
quebra-quebra meu deus em nome de jesus
toda obra de feitiçaria da trading
aparece em coral feito por eu mesmo
[Música]
a estátua na aparece outro lado fala vai
repensar o que bar thá na mão que o
menino quer saber de conversa porque ele
sabe que o mínimo que o palhaço matou
não tá vivo então ali é o capeta chegou
com capacete na cabeça do menino começa
a virar o palhaço que vai vir aqui hoje
fosse eu o menino estica o braço
esticado ou esticar a perna a cabeça
vida do palhaço
o único a se contorcer todinho virar o
capeta de parar só que ninguém quer
saber mais do meu amigo ver com capacete
é [__] na cabeça espalhar eu tomo uma
cara o palhaço começa a se transformar
em tudo aquilo que as crianças têm medo
de se transforma no pai da menina que
abusava dela e caminha pega rabi tomica
cento para se transforma no quadro
domingo ele usando mas ainda toma
parceiro para seu dormir que metem a mão
dentro da barriga do pará se estraçalhou
logo assim tudo meu amigo esse palhaço
vira muito o demônio tipo meu deus ele é
de mônica canalha tem de monte tem de
morar lá e assim muito demônios em que o
palhaço vai indo atrás dele para trás e
some ele meio que foge entendeu aí meu
amigo é aquela coisa de filme os caras
se abraça se ama tal contar um dia tá
todo mundo tranquilo mas que já esqueceu
do palhaço ia ficar calado com esta
minha vida 1 vai passar o carro sozinho
caminhando eu não ia ficar sozinho mas
nunca na minha vida eu quando fui pagar
e pedir alguém fumou segura que moça
enquanto o carro da piloto esse problema
e tem gente que não caga fora de casa ou
não cargo se alguém segurando minha mão
foi a segunda mão rápido enquanto o
cargo eu queria pedir esse coral que
cantasse pra mim tá eu pastor pregasse
pra mim ou um delicioso por aqui a mão
enquanto o senhor prega pra mim tá
palavras num show é a gerar é aquela
coisa terminou o filme eu falei pô não
se engraçado sente medo da guerra santa
se filme de terror disse kagan enquanto
permite assistir o filme esse filme aí
pai deu nem medo é de fim de ano e meio
mas foi e se você tiver gostado deste
vídeo não esquece de deixar aquele
gostei aqui tá eu quero que você comente
aqui embaixo nos comentários ao fim
você quer que eu faça o dia que eu
assisti aqui obrigado a assistir se veio
até aqui você pode seguir no instagram
no meu twitter no facebook lá no twitter
e dar rt na publicação também escreve o
canal para não perder um vídeo novo
tamo junto é nóis